kendall jenner is getting a lot of [ __ ]
for this i don't know if the 818 tequila
well
it's not even that it's kendall jenner
cultural appropriation has just
released a new line of slaves
and people are very upset now these are
haitian slaves
that the the jenner family has bought
the kardashian family
they bought 300 haitian slaves and
they're selling them on the open market
and people are angry about this and i
don't get it
but they're very angry because they
think that she's culturally
appropriating
or she shouldn't be a slave trader and
what she's doing
is it's it's a new line of slaves
um who are being treated very well
i mean this is from everything i'm
hearing they're being treated incredibly
well
they have uh health checkups and
stylists and everything like that
and she doesn't like the term slaves
she's calling them helpers
and a lot of people are getting angry at
her and i think it's unfair and i just
don't like cancel culture
i think canceled culture's got to stop
cancel culture's got to stop if a young
talented woman like kendall jenner
cannot go to haiti
and buy 300 slaves on the open market
and then sell them or libya i forget
which one but i think it's both they've
got deals different places
different suppliers she's very smart
about business
she's very smart about business this
woman and nobody
respects it and people are jealous of
her
because they didn't think to go buy
slaves
it is a smart investment
human trafficking is a major business
she's no idiot
she's no fool and people are mad at her
and it's like uh enough with the cancer
culture
stop shaming her because she's a
businesswoman
and literally and figure
figuratively wants to crack the whip
what's the big deal she's got a few
hundred slaves on the open market
no what is this tequila it's really
tequila is it slaves
i don't even know anymore i don't even
know what's a joke anymore or what's not
a joke
it's not slaves it's tequila
and people are mad at her because why
because it's mexican
because it's the area code 818 and you
know the valley yeah the valley and it's
a pro well they live in a valley
yeah they live in calabasas which i
don't really have nobody really
right nobody thinks of that they don't
think of calabasas when they think of
the valley
but so she's appropriating the area code
818.
yeah and it's also like it's mexican
territory because you know they've
worked really hard to have tequila
brands but
people have pointed out that george
clooney and all these other big
celebrities have tequila companies too
so yeah there's not a ton of mexicans
with tequila companies my maid does not
own a tequila company
what i understand she's drunk on tequila
and doesn't do any work
but she i don't think she owns the
company by the way i'm not saying all
mexicans have maids either but you know
what i mean
she is my maids are made she ain't a
good one
so the problem is that we max what is
the problem
she's appropriating like jalisco
is the city where apparently they create
a lot of the tequila
yeah it's been like hundreds of years
these families have been
you know making these tequila companies
and been working very hard on them and
she just sort of trots in
and says this is just kendall just get
slaves
if they're gonna get mad at you anyway
just
get slaves
i mean i wanna the next time people
comment these two girls
i wanna see them doing a slave auction
in the middle of beverly hills
with libyan slaves
they're gonna get mad anyway
i don't know if there's this is a
problem jalisco is where they make the
tequila
that's what i was reading yeah kendall's
the loser kylie's the billionaire
kendall's got nothing going on so she's
just trying to
wet her beak with a little tequila
she should just lean in and start
selling [ __ ]
taco kits old el paso should [ __ ]
partner with kendall jenner
kendall jenner should become every
everything mexican
like just lean in start
just open up a trendy arepas restaurant
which are venezuelan but whatever it's
late
um but that's what she should do she
should call tacos by kendall
tacos by kendall she should just say
[ __ ] it
i'm gonna sell mexican [ __ ] who cares
like this person was mad on twitter they
said tired of the celebrity tequila
craze
wtf does kendall jenner know about
tequila my family's been doing
back-breaking work in fields for their
entire lives in jalisco just for people
to come here here's what kendall jenner
knows about the kids she knows is
drinking it and getting in a range rover
and driving home and not getting caught
she knows about consuming it she knows
about taking a few
shots of it and falling into a [ __ ]
escalade
that's what she knows about it she knows
about drinking a lot of it and then
going and sucking off a rapper
it's alcohol stop making it into like a
spiritual thing it's booze
right isn't it booze
what has this woman work she's never
worked in a field you're on twitter
you're in the field you're on twitter
what field are you in
you can take time to tweet i see people
in the fields none of them have a phone
what did she take the phone out she's in
the field going my family
you know what they would say they go get
the [ __ ] work
i am taking it to kendall jenner
i am i'm wrecking candle jammer
get get your [ __ ] hands
on the crop but i must
no hold on i am sending a tweet
who's this with the tweet this is our
last episode on youtube
i'm going to burn this hotel down it
hurts
a spoon an hour ago it's not here she
doesn't look like she works in the
fields
i'll turn this around for you
the fields
the fields yeah she lives in
i'm not saying people shouldn't be
pissed about this but the people that
should be pissed at this are working
right they're in trouble
they're not concerned about kendall
jenner trying to do want someone to let
him out of a cage
i mean so what is the whole tweet i
didn't even
oh uh tired of celebrity tequila craze
wtf does kendall jenner know about
tequila my family's been doing back
breaking work in the fields for their
entire lives in jalisco
just for people to come dip their toes
stay in your lane
stay in your lane yeah i'll start a
mexican tequila company
so what and she's this other person says
she's not to mention she's profiting off
the brown hands that actually plant
grow harvest ferment and distill
everyone but that's everyone's
the hands of everything yeah
i've got no love loss for uh
who are they again the kardashian i
don't care about these people
and they don't they don't factor into my
life at all but to just get mad at them
and not get mad at everybody else who's
profiting off the brown hands in the
fields
right right now you're right so many
people have
uh tequila companies george clooney
right yeah
clooney
oj should start a liquor company
o.j should start a booze company
he's black he's loud yeah cares